amazon is under increasing scrutiny from
president trump as we've been saying he
accuses the online retailer of bilking
Americans by abusing the US Postal
Service
tonight correspondent Gillian Turner
tells us we could be getting close to a
change in that arrangement the post
office is losing billions of dollars and
the taxpayers are paying for that money
because it delivers packages for Amazon
at a very below cost the much-maligned
deal between USPS and Amazon has been in
place for five years and it's set to
expire in October now tech insiders tell
Fox News that new leaders appointed by
the President himself may soon take the
reins at the struggling agency and
determine the deals fate president
Trump's nominated three people to the
USPS Board of Governors the executive
body that oversees all its major
decisions they are Calvin Tucker
chairman of the Philadelphia black
Republican Council Robert Duncan
chairman of the President's Commission
on white house fellowships and David
Williams former inspector general for
USPS if these nominees are confirmed by
the Senate later this month president
Trump's views on Amazon will be front
and center there'd be three people
appointed by Trump in in a position of
authority and power to say to the sales
department hey we want you to take a
more strategic look at this Amazon
contract but experts caution that a
better deal with Amazon won't fix the
Postal Service's larger problems the
Postal Service has been in a crisis
since about 1995 they've been losing
money for years and years the culprit of
the crisis the rise of the internet an
Americans preference for communicating
via email in just a decade between 2002
and 2012 first-class letter delivery in
the u.s. dropped by almost 30 percent
from one hundred and 2.4 billion pieces
of mail to only seventy three point five
billion and in the first quarter of this
year alone letter volume dropped a
further five percent but despite this
dismal picture experts identify one
bright spot on the horizon packages the
growing part
of the post office business is parcel
delivery and the shrinking part
continuing to shrink of the post offices
business is first-class mail
even if packages continue to pick up
USPS faces other financial burdens
courtesy of Congress a 2006 law requires
the Postal Service to pre-fund health
benefits for the retired employees a
burden that costs 5.5 billion dollars
per year Brett Jillian thank you